journal spécial le camping l'eau seule
fac est ce un spectacle de fin du monde
déjà 114 de cercueils il y en aura
d'autres les circonstances de l'accident
les premiers témoignages avec nos
envoyés spéciaux bruno alba et bernard
marchetti à paris simone veil -le les
hôpitaux français sont prêts pour
accueillir les grands brûlés le
président carter antenne 2 les pays
industrialisés doivent jouer la
solidarité une interview de jacques
séguin monsieur bonsoir tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé depuis ce matin la confection
de ce journal on dans les yeux pour
longtemps encore deux images l'une de
désolation un camping rayé de la carte
touristique espagnol celui de l'eau
seule fac est loin de tarragone c'est à
dire entre barcelone et valence
l'autre est presque aux siens tout
insoutenable c'est celle d'un petit
cimetière non loin de là le petit
cimetière de tortona jusqu'à ce matin et
a scellé un cimetière comme les autres
c'est allé se sont transformés
aujourd'hui en une gigantesque chapelle
ardente 114e cercueil déjà les 114 morts
officiels de la catastrophe hier après
midi ils sont 126 déjà ce soir et il y
en aura d'autres de très nombreux brûlé
en tout près de 600 leçon très gravement
un seul exemple celui de l'hôpital
francisco franco à barcelone les
médecins viennent de dire que le sur les
35 brûlé qu'ils sont en train de soigner
deux seulement pourront être sauvés
renault albin et patrick derrien nos
correspondants permanents l'espagne sont
parmi les premiers journalistes être
parvenu sur le camping de l'osce à la
caisse il n'y a pas de mots pour dire ce
qui s'est passé à san carlos vela rapid
à seulement des visages hagards
seulement des silhouettes fantomatiques
et grise les carcasses noircies des
caravanes des jouets calciné seulement
des ruines et encore quelques fumées
tragédie drame catastrophe
les deux explosions qui ont ravagé en
l'espace de cinq secondes le terrain de
camping de l'eau sale fagiht ont
provoqué quelque chose qui n'a pas de
nom
vous avez compté combien disons trop
forte
en fait après les bouteilles de gaz
qu'ils sont partis moins sensiblement se
tait serrières m'enfin donc il ya eu la
langue de feu sur la route le la grosse
explosion plus la deuxième explosion ou
mon père a été brûlée qui est venu ici
commune comme une flamme commun un
soufflet pas aimer les matelas ont été
soulevées
incroyable comment voulez que je veux
c'est ce qu'ils ont entendu un gros
bruit je reviendrai demain je me suis
levé il ya là j'ai vu ce truc allait
contester une caravane qui sont j'ai vu
un truc en l'air comme ça je crois que
c'était une caravane qui sautait le
temps concours ça nous est tombé sur la
voiture ça la voiture a pris feu
on a couru j'ai réalisé que j'avais ma
petite foule qui dormait dans la
caravane 80 mon mari est revenu seront
ses parts dans la petite juste avec toi
flammes mais on a couru tous à la plage
on est tous ainsi sauf essentiel on a
tout perdu mais ça fait rien c'est vrai
je ne servais tout comme après tino
rossi que ce curieux
au contraire c'était la fin du monde ça
c'est arrivé comme une solution comme
problème on sait pas quoi ça commence et
les gens criaient tout le monde avait
perdu toute foi pratiquement on peut
dire qu'il n'ya pas eu véritablement
incendie c'était dantesque de voir tous
ces morts
étendu sur le sol oui c'est vrai ils
étaient figés dans l'attitude même où
les avait surpris la panique et il y
avait des cadavres qui n'avait même pas
été atteint par les flammes
il avait été tué par la simple
propagation de la chaleur mais moi j'ai
dit à ma femme d'aller s'éloigner et
puis je suis parti puis après j'ai pensé
il est quelqu'un que j'ai eu personne
j'ai pensé au bout d'un dernier
c'est une voisine qui n'y étaient pas je
n'ai jamais récupéré toi puisse a fêté
sa pt au métal et parce que ça se
faisait arrosée vous êtes revenu après
et apprenez je suis revenu pour il y
avait plein de brûler
le bordelais vers mes affaires de 4
minutes cinq minutes ou si tu m'appeler
sa durée 90j a été longue et déjà revenu
de très longs mais oui mais c'est long
et mais savez c'est il ya eu il ya eu le
bouge support est le poumon
le gars s'est propagé brûlant et il ya
eu un autre explosion et là il ya eu un
souffle même parce que je suis allé sur
les lieux
il ya des endroits où je suis quel écart
n ya plus rien attendre caravanes ont
brûlé mais la carcasse là y'a plus rien
il ya des voitures que je savais qu'elle
était garée au bord de mer
elles y sont plus toute la nuit on l'a
passé ici entre l'espérance et le
désespoir
on a cherché parmi les décombres une
raison d'être éveillé on a passé de
longues heures à espérer ne pas
découvrir qu'il n'y avait plus
d'expérience possible
on a vu des hommes des femmes seules
chercher les leurs on a vu entrer à
l'hôpital de tortosa à quelques
kilomètres de san carlos un homme
terrassé par un infarctus
cinq minutes avant le drame il était
aller téléphoner il est revenu pour
découvrir ses deux enfants et sa femme
mort brûlé vif
toute la nuit on a vu grandir
l'impressionnant le glaçante alignement
des cercueils dans l'allée aussi près du
cimetière de tortosa aux premières
lueurs de l'aube ils étaient 10 et 11
113 auxquels devaient s'ajouter deux
cents blessés dont 50 étaient
considérées comme perdues mais toute la
nuit dans les hôpitaux de madrid à
barcelone et de tarragona valence ceux
des blessés qui ne luttait pas contre la
mort se sont battus contre une vision
d'enfer ça s'est passé tellement vite
quelques fractions qu'est ce que vous
avez fait des ravages
j'ai vu une nappe de gaz qui s'est ici
est répandu sur des flammes les fleurs
mox est exposée par ci par là j'y joue
ce le temps de cours et à vous seuls à
face la place
et puis dans le brouillard passé j'étais
plein de gaz par moi j'ai eu la chance
manger j'ai pu en sortir parce que je
pas puis le même le même chemin que des
gens vraiment
les mots je ne sais pas du tout la
nature du chef est ce que vous vous êtes
rendu dans la soirée
vous êtes rendu compte de ce qui se
passe est une grand explosion a commencé
au moment où ça s'est passé vous étiez
ou dans votre tente donc qu'un matin
entre manger tout le monde c'est souvent
ça a été la panique 3 la grande panique
un petit
très vite
vous n'avez pas encore très bien compris
à quoi pensez-vous
les champs
et je sais bien qu'il n'a eu comme
acquise en révision dudit rester sur
tout ce qui faisait tout ce qui était au
bord de l'eau jour plus qu'en sortir
ouais ils vont être bouché
ce matin à san carlos dolara pita le
soleil de la catalogne n'a fait que se
lever sur une immense tristesse ce matin
de juillet avait des allures de novembre
derrière les petits murs du camping
delos alpha guest la mère est restée
seule les rochers noirs ci est désert
plus tôt dans les cyprès de tortosa a
couru du fond de la nuit des pères des
mères des frères des soeurs des enfants
tentaient d'identifier leur nouvelle
solitude elle personne ne contrainte
pour que les choses soient bien claires
je vous propose à l'aide de cette carte
de mieux comprendre les circonstances de
l'accident
alors nous sommes donc sur la route
nationale barcelone valence le camion se
trouvait là au moment où il a heurté le
petit muret et on retrouve la citerne du
camion à 500 m de là tombé dans un bar
la roux ici la cabine du camion en face
les cieux en plein dans le camping tout
ça c'est le camping
le souffle a donc été horrible toute
cette partie du contrat ping a
entièrement été brûlés
le dancing qui se trouvent ici a été
soufflée par l'explosion et tous les
survivants que vous avez pu entendre se
trouvait donc dans cette partie
relativement préservée du camping et sur
la plage et sur la mairie ou alors
civile de la province de tarragone à
d'ailleurs décidé d'interdire la
circulation des camions citernes sur les
routes nationales
ils devront désormais emprunter les
autoroutes j'ajoute que dans un premier
temps une polémique est née à propos du
rapatriement des blessés vers la france
ce matin les espagnols qui estiment ne
pas avoir besoin de l'aide étrangère
et de fait des médecins sur place ont
constaté que les soins étaient
remarquables les espagnols ont donc
interdit cette évacuation des blessés en
direction de leur pays d'origine
mais finalement les difficultés ont été
aplanies en début d'après midi
europ assistance a notamment pu
acheminer de nombreux blessés graves
vers la france et vers la belgique
par ailleurs deux boeing ouest allemands
sont chargés de rapatrier vers bonn les
blessés allemand transportable vous
imaginez bien sûr qu'il est très
difficile d'avoir à la fois un bilan et
une liste des victimes et des blessés
si bien qu'on ait finalement
trouver un tacle le registre du camping
mais on peut toutefois avoir des
précisions sur l'état des blessés en
appelant deux numéros à tarragone le 19
34 77 21 01 00 et le 19 34 77 44 00 00
par ailleurs vous pouvez également avoir
des nouvelles sur vos familles en
appelant le ministère des affaires
étrangères à paris c'est à dire le 501
59 40 à partir de demain matin 8h 559
carte deuxième équipe d'antenne 2 à
pénétrer sur le camping celle de bernard
marchetti et de patrick esther qui ont
donc découvert dans la matinée un
spectacle motion a eu lieu en amont de
la route vers la montagne il y avait une
discothèque un club discothèque qui a
été complètement rasée cela nous donne
l'idée de la puissance de l'explosion il
n'y a pas eu de victimes parce que à
14h30 les clubs discothèques sont des
verts
mais de ce côté ci de la route vers la
mer alors ça a été le drame la
catastrophe
il y avait là des dizaines de tentes des
dizaines de caravanes et de voitures et
puis des centaines de gens parce que
tout le monde était là c'était tout de
suite après le repas ce n'était pas
encore l'heure du bain et toutes les
familles étaient réunies
on sait cependant que certaines
personnes qui aient été brûlés se sont
dirigés vers la mer et ont essayé
d'éteindre les flammes en entrant dans
l'eau et c'est pour cela que depuis ce
matin des plongeurs sous-marins
inspectent la côte pour éventuellement
retrouver des corps
les autorités sont du reste persuadé que
le nombre des victimes va s'alourdir
encore aux morts il faudra ajouter les
disparus le pire c'est peut-être encore
l'incertitude alors de france
d'allemagne de belgique des gens
arrivent sans arrêt à la recherche de
proches parents
certains ont le bonheur d'être vite
rassuré les autres aires dans le camping
attendant des informations qui n'arrive
que par bribes
oui volontairement nous n'avons pas fait
comme ses photographes nous avons fait
le choix de ne vous montrez que les
images les moins éprouvante si je puis
dire des corps calcinés
la france je voulais dire faire sa
solidarité à l'espagne ce fut même
d'ailleurs le premier sujet être abordée
par le chef de l'état en conseil des
ministres ce matin et à l'issue de ce
conseil simone veil -le de mise de la
santé disait que tout serait fait pour
accueillir à n'importe quel moment
les blessés étaient à 3 nous sommes en
liaison avec les autorités espagnoles
avec notre ambassade et nous faisons
tout pour à la fois aider tous les
blessés quelle que soit leur nationalité
en coopération qui autorise plus que
tout que denis convaincants les hôpitaux
français va nous avons fait en tout cas
moi j'étais en conseil ce matin toute la
matinée mais en tout cas je sais que
nous avons recensé tous les lits
disponibles de grands brûlés qui sont
susceptibles d'accueillir des blessés à
n'importe quel moment et en même temps
tous les samu sont alertés pour pouvoir
éventuellement aussi par ailleurs le
chef de l'état chargé olivier stirn son
saut catalina aux affaires étrangères de
se rendre en espagne ce qui la fin début
d'après-midi pour coordonner les
problèmes que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
les problèmes des ressortissants
français
vous avez été très nombreux à nous
appeler pour nous offrir toutes sortes
de concours par exemple beaucoup ont
proposé de se faire prélever une partie
de la peau pour soigner les grands
brûlés c'est inutile sachez le en
revanche les dons du sang sont les
bienvenus il est certain que
les brûlés ont besoin d'une équipe c'est
à dire d'un chirurgien plastique et de
réanimateur anesthésiste qui remplace
les liquides perdu au cours de la
brûlure et qui s'efforce dans les zones
brûlées pour refaire une nouvelle peau
soit provisoirement avec des hommes au
greffe c'est à dire des grèves prix sur
des cadavres ou sur des porcs mais assez
rapidement avec leur peau à eux ils vous
comprenez très bien que c'est pour cela
qu'il faut que ce soit pas trop brûlé
parce qu'il faut trouver de la peau pour
leur remettre pour leur bouche et leur
trou elle
et quels sont les brûlures les plus
graves sont les brosses exactement
celles qui se sont produites en espagne
sont les brûlures de guerre sont des
brûlures des aviateurs bloqués dans
leurs avions sont les murs des
automobilistes bloqués dans leurs
voitures qui flambent c'est la brûlure
pare-flammes les vêtements brûle c'est
la pire de toutes
et la médecine est elle impuissante à ce
niveau là la chirurgie plastique peut
guérir des brûlés dans quelques cas
heureux jusqu'à 60 à 70% la surface du
corps mais lorsqu'elle y arrivent sont
des patients qu'on présente toujours
dans les congrès et pour savoir pourquoi
c'est brûler le sont si gravement
pourquoi certains le sont à 100% c'est à
dire vous l'avez entendu sans aucune
chance de survie il faut répéter ce que
nous disions hier dans ce même journal
à savoir donc la fiche technique du
propylène georges plaire à partir du
pétrole une grande raffinerie comme
celle-ci fabrique énormément de produits
dangereux comme l'essence le gaz en
bouteille le mazout des produits qui
peuvent brûler voir exploser quand on
les manies sans précaution pourtant tous
les jours vous en manipuler un peu dans
votre chaudière votre voiture votre
briquet dans une raffinerie ces produits
dangereux sont créés en grande quantité
des précautions énormes sont prises la
sécurité et par tous les moyens
d'intervention aussi
le propylène circule à travers la
raffinerie dans les tuyaux il sert même
parfois au refroidissement
c'est dire s'il est utilisé de façon
courante bien avant d'être transformé en
matière plastique ou en détergents en
fait dans la catastrophe d'hier de
propylène n'est pas le grand coupable
n'importe quel gaza flamme à ben
liquéfié sous pression contenue dans une
grosse citerne qui explose aurait
pratiquement conduit aux mêmes effets
désastreux
pas plus que l'on ne remette en cause l'
usage du gaz lorsqu'il détruit un
immeuble
il ne faut condamner le propylène si
utile par ailleurs simplement les
précautions pour son transport doivent
être renforcés en espagne comme partout
enfin troisième série de questions que
vous êtes comme nous posez les
assurances qui paiera qui a des mises
rats et comment faut avouer que dans
l'état actuel de l'enquêté les
responsabilités restent encore bien
diffuse une enquête de elisabeth et zélé
auprès du centre technique des
assurances il est difficile encore de
déterminer qui du transporteur ou du
propriétaire du produit pourrait être
responsable ou éventuellement les deux
de toute façon eu la chance extrêmement
élevé existe elle est très élevée
puisqu'elle s'élève à presque 10
milliards de centimes
et de l'avis du technicien qui nous a
parlé le l'assurance eut pierre pour
indemniser les victimes
ceci bien entendu sous réserve que ces
informations se confirmer par la suite
du côté des victimes est-ce que les
contrats d'assurance souscrits en france
sont valables en espagne je suis
concerné contrats d'assurance sur la vie
ils sont toujours valables en espagne en
ce qui concerne les contrats d'assurance
contre les accidents corporels ce qu'on
appelle les contrats dation indivis
l'accident la plupart sinon la totalité
est également valable en espagne en ce
qui concerne les voitures qui évidemment
sont un problème qui comparé aux
blessé aux victimes et d'un problème
mineur mais enfin qui intéresse quand
même les propriétés à nos deux meules il
en suit concerne les voitures en france
la plupart des gens sentent assuré
contre le vol et l'incendié la plupart
des contrats d'assurance chantera cet
égard dans la brenne espagne figure
aucune nouvelle catastrophe a été évitée
de justesse en espagne un camion qui
transportait 400 bons bonne de butane
explosé au nord de madrid
le chauffeur a eu beaucoup de sang froid
il y avait un début d'incendié dans sa
cabine il a arrêté le véhicule sur un
parking et à bloquer immédiatement toute
la circulation
l'explosion qui a suivi peu après a été
énorme beaucoup de dégâts matériels mais
par chance aucun blessé
tout cela repose fut une nouvelle fois
le problème du transport des matières
dangereuses par la route
nous ouvrirons ce dossier d'une manière
très complète demain avec la vie d'un
chauffeur de camion qui précisément
transporte du propylène en france mais
il faut quand même savoir tout de suite
que la majeure partie des transports de
propylène est effectué par voie ferrée
ou bien par gazoduc
voilà je crois tout ce que nous pouvions
dire ce soir sur cette tragédie de l'eau
sale fera qu est ce qui a fait la une de
tous les journaux européens sans
exception
je rappelle qu'il y avait énormément de
touristes français mais aussi
d'allemands de belges et de néerlandais
demain également nous ouvrions le
dossier des campings parfois surchargées
c'était le cas en espagne 800 personnes
pour 250 places mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas pour autant traumatisé les gens
et surtout les campeurs en puissance à
la veille d'un nouveau départ en
vacances un départ qui devrait être
difficile très difficile même en france
les la journée de demain est celle de
vendredi seront surchargées alors une
fois de plus suivez bien les consignes
du ministère de l'équipement et de soi
porte-parole bison futé pour jeudi 13
éviter 15h 21h et pour vendredi 14
éviter 8h12 de toute façon vous serez
aidé par ses anges gardiens de la route
que sont les crs des anges au double
visage puisqu'ils sont aussi chargés
vous savez de réprimer les infractions
alain dubus qui a vécu quelques jours
avec
si vous utilisez l'autoroute pour partir
en vacances vous avez peut être remarqué
ces bornes d'appel d'urgence
elles sont reliées téléphoniquement à
des postes de contre ces postes sont en
contact radio avec les patrouilles de
police et équipés de caméras vidéo
ce matériel perfectionné permettent une
surveillance continue des autoroutes 10
de dégagements les plus encombrées les
plus dangereux aussi rocade échangeurs
souterrain ne facilite pas la conduite
la surveillance de ces autoroutes de
dégagement conçu spécialement pour
absorber la circulation des jours de
grands départs et de la compétence
exclusive et compagnies républicaines de
sécurité
les crs
le ici marteau reçu ce ralentissement a
provoqué par une densité de circulation
correct
cette surveillance permet une rapidité
d'intervention indispensable par forte
circulation le connu plus projet
conducteur les motards en quoi
peuvent-ils aider les usagers consiste à
enseigner ce qu'ils ont perdu parce que
le réseau d'autoroutes dans la région
actuellement et sans du kanak arrive à
se tromper en plus
alors souvent en panne ou alors pour des
petites pannes mécaniques
est-ce que vous avez également avant
leurs respectifs auront apprécié prix
ont oublié de la voir le rôle répressif
pour ce qui est quand même des gens qui
sont juliette tout à l'heure trop
fougueuse toit lorsque ces bouchers
circulent sur les bandes d'arrêt
d'urgence
ça pourrait créer une gêne lorsque les
services de police sont obligés
d'intervenir toits qu'il roule sur la
voie de gauche à une vitesse très
réduite
sagen seigneur
et vous
lorsque la circulation des trains
transportant six à la vitesse comme un
saumon zones d'habitat dans le vendée à
110 km heure nous faisons les poteaux
les crs n'ont pas voulu limiter leur
rôle à ces deux aspects des dés de
police de la houle conscient de
l'intérêt des jeunes pour la moto il
propose des pistes d'initiation à la
conduite de séville
cette initiation débute par un contrôle
des connaissances en matière de code de
la cette première épreuve passée le
jeune peut alors s'entraîner à la
conduite en postes fixes sur home
trainer
puis c'est la conduite sur piste en
double commande le moniteur guide
l'élève à l'aide des organes de commande
on est sur un guidon fixé entre le
passager et le conducteur
enfin le candidat reconnu apte à
conduire seul un vélomoteur
la police nous at-on dit n'est pas
hostile aux jeunes sur deux roues mais
elle les préfère bien préparé
quel temps rencontreront pour ces
vacanciers du week-end 10 bien les
nouvelles sont assez optimistes vous
l'avez vous aujourd'hui la journée a été
relativement belle sur l'ensemble du
pays malgré les orages et des nuages sur
le nord je vous laisse découvrir la
carte est parfois sur le bassin parisien
ça c'était le temps d'aujourd'hui demain
donc un ciel bleu et assez ensoleillé
sur toute la france
quelques nuages sur les massifs
montagneux des alpes aux beaux chats ça
arrange la sphère politique maintenant
avec l'évocation de la tragédie
espagnole en conseil des ministres ce
matin
le gouvernement a également entériné une
augmentation de 3 à 4% des salaires du
personnel de la fonction publique
rétroactivement c'est à dire à compter
du 1er juin dernier
deuxième dossier du conseil airbus sa
nouvelle version le b10 semble être
promu à un bel avenir
ces premiers exemplaires seront
livrables fin 82 enfin une nomination
celle de 6000 simon à la direction
générale des postes c'est une mission
intéressante car elle semble indiquer
une légère inflexion dans la politique
de nos revers se garent en matière de
ptt un socialiste à l'elysée tout à
l'heure valéry giscard d'estaing
recevait aujourd'hui roger quilliot le
maire de clermont ferrand mais au type
de président de l'association des maires
des grandes villes de france
au centre de cet entretien un projet de
loi de décentralisation dont le
parlement aura à débattre à l'automne et
qui devrait se traduire par une
décentralisation importante des
responsabilités au profit des mères
pendant ce temps le premier ministre lui
félicité les premiers prix du concours
général 78 que christian de lacq le
ministre de l'éducation a des réunis sur
les pelouses du ministère cent trente
lycéens
cinquante quatre filles et 73 garçons
une cuvée paraît-il un peu moins bonne
que les précédentes car plusieurs prix
n'ont pas été décerné ce que vous avez
fait jusqu'à présent leur a dit raymond
barre n'est rien à côté de ce qu'il vous
reste à faire
mais guère encourageant pour ces
valeureux lauret et puis surtout par les
ministres en a profité pour donner un
coup de chapeau
je voudrais que tous les français
comprennent à quel point la mission
difficile qui est celle du corps
enseignant est important pour l'avenir
de la collectivité nationale
un pays vaut finalement ce que vaut son
système d'éducation et ce système
d'éducation vaut ce que valent ces m
cette vérité d'évidence et sans doute
encore plus actuel lorsque comme
aujourd'hui l'objectif est d'étendre le
bénéfice l'enseignement secondaire à
tous les jeunes français sans que cette
démocratisation indispensable entraîne
une baisse du niveau de notre
enseignement
cet objectif ne pourra être atteint qu'à
force de méthodes de compétences et
d'enthousiastes je sais que nos maîtres
n'en manque pas et je voudrais leur dire
que le gouvernement apprécie leurs
efforts et leur en est reconnaissant
pour en finir avec les affaires
françaises j'ajoute que georges marchais
a définitivement perdu son procès contre
minutes et la nation française devant la
cour d'appel de paris aujourd'hui le
secrétaire général du pc avait porté
plainte contre les deux journaux pour
usage de faux documents savoir les fac
similé d'un certificat l'embauchent du
st lô en allemagne en 1940 de monsieur
marché soutient qu'ils y étaient partie
contraint et forcé justice toujours la
traduction de mein kampf le livre
d'adolphe hitler que je vous avais
montré le mois dernier pourra être
diffusée en france mais avec des annexes
c'est-à-dire le texte de 72 sur le
racisme et le jugement de nuremberg
condamnant les criminels nazis
le tribunal civil de paris a par
ailleurs accordé 80 mille francs de
dommages et intérêts à la ligue contre
le racisme et l'antisémitisme
enfin georges beaufils l'espion français
qui avait travaillé au profit des
soviétiques a été condamné à huit ans de
détention criminelle
ainsi en a décidé la cour de sûreté de
l'état l'instant le sport maintenant
étape insolite ce matin dans le tour de
france les coureurs ont franchi la ligne
d'arrivée à pied ils étaient en grève
on les avait obligés à prendre le départ
trop tôt c'est la première manifestation
d'humeur de gens dans l'ain tour de
france les organisateurs ont aussitôt
décidé d'annuler la première des
méthodes de la journée
vent de révolte donc ce matin sur le
tour les coureurs ont roulé à 20 à
l'heure avant de s'immobiliser à
quelques mètres de la ligne c'est la
troisième fois qu'une grève paralyse le
tour que vous l'êtes ont protesté contre
les organisateurs
les coureurs après la dure étape d'école
hier ont dû se lever ce matin à 5 heures
pour couvrir 240 km 5 ou 6 heures de
sommeil
c'est peu pour récupérer mais le profil
du tour étant connue depuis le mois de
décembre dernier les coureurs avaient
bien le temps de s'inquiéter de tout
cela auparavant le préjudice causé au
tour de france au public et à la ville
de valence d'agen est considérable
hinault que vous voyez ici avec son
maillot tricolore
l'un des meneurs de la grève propose de
disputer un critérium à valence d'agen
après le tour quant au résultat de la
demi étape on vous l'a dit ils ont été
annulés à noter enfin que des
spectateurs mécontents ont pris à partie
les coureurs au départ de la demi étape
cet après midi alors cette deuxième des
miettes appel s'est déroulée normalement
c'est jacques esclassan tu qu'il l'a
emporté très facilement vous allez le
voir avec plus d'une longueur d'avancé
sur le peloton il a franchi la ligne
d'arrivée devant europe et et mertens
joseph bruyère conserve son maillot
jaune
aucun changement de roncq au classement
général
jacques esclassan c'est donc le coureur
en blanc avec panier mois noirs de
voiliers se détacher et gagner la grande
étape c'était celle d'hier
la première belle étape de montagne avec
vous l'avez vu des grands vainqueurs
mais aussi de grandes défaillances et ce
sont ces souffrances là qu'on choisit de
ce côté nos deux envoyés spéciaux pas
comme les autres sur le toit
daniel bilalian yves bonsergent ils
n'ont pas caracoler avec les échappés
ils sont restés à l'arrière et ils ont
vécu quelques abandons vous allez le
voir assez dramatique du tour de france
donc par daniel bilalian
et ils vont sergent
dallas a
enfin gérard bon une réponse qui suppose
pourtant maire de nant
voir
le ton monte
vas-y amber à toute allure
c'est un peu et bien à l'est qu'à gauche
enfin en vain
michel galopin 23 ans
depuis cinq jours il courait avec la
clavicule cassée
il prend le brassard à la danse
alors rien
et en salle mais l'anglais barry hoban
38 ans vétéran du tout
et
col du tourmalet 2113 m
alors gare à elle qu'à bien fini
un autre
conserver toute façon il n'ya pas de
miracle
c'était plus que tu ne pouvais faire
soigner qui a recommencé un
prochainement
j'ai tu pourras pour vous et vous les
comptines absolument avec notre
clavicule pourtant les médecins allaient
trt mais tout ça c'est fini
pour la france on essaie toujours de
tenir
enfin dernier dossier de ce journal vous
le comprenez beaucoup plus longs qu'à
l'habitude
la politique étrangère une entrevue
d'importance tout à l'heure à l'elysée
celle du ministre algérienne l'avait
grand cher monsieur bouteflika a reçu
pendant une heure et quart par le chef
de l'état visiblement la confirmation à
la sortie d'un certain dégel entre paris
et alger
est ce qu'il ya une décrispation alors
des relations franco algériennes après
cet entretien qui a duré plus d'une
heure oui je crois que je peux parler de
décrispation bien que personnellement je
n'ai jamais été crispés en politique
je crois qu'il faut mettre
ces ressentiments originaire il faut
toujours la tête froide mis très clair
nous n'avons pas les approcher
allal el
convergentes plus exactement sur tous
les problèmes qui se posent à l'afrique
au monde arabe au monde de façon
générale mais ce que je puis dire c'est
que nous avons décidé d'un commun accord
de discuter un peu plus dorénavant pour
si vous voulez éviter les initiatives
qui font que l'on ait agi sans la
connaissance ou dans la méconnaissance
des positions de
votre paternel que pensez vous
personnellement de ce qui s'est passé en
mauritanie
je crois que tous les intéressés sans
dans la tente
la nouvelle équipe vient de prendre le
pouvoir il faut lui donner le temps de
consolider son pouvoir de s'organiser
j'ai appris avec une réelle satisfaction
tout alors que le polisario par exemple
a décidé de faire un cessez-le-feu
unilatéral provisoire
lui aussi est dans la tente un effet
donc je confirme le front polisario a
bien décrété aujourd'hui un
cessez-le-feu en mauritanie
deux jours après le putsch de nouakchott
le front polisario c'est à dire les
rebelles sahraouis jusqu alors hostiles
à l'ancien régime de mokhtar ould daddah
pays basque- nouvel attentat ce matin en
espagne la voie ferrée qui relie san
sebastien à la frontière française a été
détruite à l'explosif et de nouveaux
incidents ont éclaté dans la ville des
manifestants ont tenté d'ériger des
barricades
enfin toujours à l'étranger alors que
les procès se poursuive en urss
une rencontre gromyko vente à genève
pendant tuner monsieur vance a exposé à
son collègue soviétique andreï gromyko
la position américaine sur la limitation
des armements stratégiques telle a été
l'essentiel de ces retrouvailles entre
le deux ministres à genève c'est peu le
porte parole du département d'état a
encore indiqué que cyrus vance était
porteur d'un message du président carter
destiné à leonid brejnev
dans ce document le président américain
réaffirmant terme énergique l'intérêt
des états unis pour la défense des
droits de l'homme en urss
monsieur vance souhaite d'ailleurs
obtenir des explications sur la
répression sévère qui frappe les
dissidents soviétiques ainsi les procès
de stars en ski et gainsbourg suscite
une certaine tension autour de la
rencontre de genève
madame stern ce qui sera d'ailleurs reçu
demain par le secrétaire d'état
américain au procès de son mari poursuit
vers moscou pour trahison et espionnage
le huis clos a été levée le frère de
l'accusé a pu suivre l'audience
d'aujourd'hui
quant au procès alexandre gainsbourg
accusé de propagande anti soviétique
le procureur a requis une peine de huit
ans de détention à l'encontre de
l'écrivain
la situation des dissidents soviétiques
voilà l'un des thèmes abordés par le
président carter dans un entretien qu'il
devienne accordée à un journaliste
français
notre correspondant jaaksi ainsi qu'à
trois autres de ses confrères étrangers
et ceci à la veille du voyage qu'il
entreprend en allemagne fédérale il sera
demain et doit rester quatre jours ce
qui lui permettra d'assister au sommet
de bonn en fin de semaine voici donc
pour antenne de cette interio du numéro
un mec
les procès de moscou heurte la
conscience américaine comme ils frappent
la conscience du monde entier car ils
sont contraires naturellement à l'esprit
des droits de là il n'est pas question
d'autre part que les états unis
sacrifient leurs propres intérêts au
détriment de l'intérêt de la communauté
occidentale sur le plan économique
enfin concernant l'afrique les
américains travaillent ardemment avec de
nombreuses nations africaines et
européennes et ils ne veulent pas
quitter l'afrique ce sont les trois
points que je retiens de l'interview du
président américain que je vous invite
maintenant à regarder
ces allégations et cela complique nos
relations avec l'union soviétique oui
nous sommes profondément engagés dans la
détente
heureusement l'union soviétique aussi la
détente doit reposer sur une base large
est réciproque
oui nos copains nous pensons que nos
négociations sur la réduction des
armements atomiques sont capitales pour
nous comme pour eux et pour le monde
un terroir exposition nous n'avons
jamais permis que rien interrompre nos
efforts pour arriver à la conclusion des
négociations salt
il y a des différences entre nous et
l'union soviétique des formes
différentes de gouvernement
désormais nous sommes en concurrence
avec l'union soviétique
oui nous croyons qu'il faut encourager
la paix ne pas s'immiscer dans les
affaires des autres et à protéger les
droits fondamentaux de l'homme
reconnaître le droit absolu de chaque
nation de choisir son gouvernement
ces principes démocratiques l'urss ne
les respectent pas leur philosophie de
la vie
différentes il faut tenir compte de ces
différences sans craindre la compétition
un autre défi vous attend un fun de la
part de la france et de l'allemagne
est-ce que cela vous contrarie de
constater que certaines nations
européennes affirment leur volonté
d'indépendance
sur le plan économique active les
statines indépendance
il ne panique pas laisser une avance aux
etats unis nous avons toujours été
favorable à une europe forte à une
alliance forte économiquement et
politiquement
bien sûr nous participons à l'alliance
militaire qui protège la liberté de
l'europe
je ne pense pas qu'à bonne on cherchera
à provoquer une baisse du dollar ni à
élever des barrières commerciales contre
les produits américains
si cela se produit nous le déplorons
riom mais je n'y crois pas nous
souscrivons renforcement de la
communauté économique européenne et bien
sûr et bien sûr est l'unité politique de
l'europe aussi selon vous les intérêts
américains passent avant ou après la
solidarité occidentale afin de ne pas re
trouve qu'il est difficile de distinguer
les uns des eaux la solidarité
occidentale est une donnée essentielle
de l'intérêt des états unis croit mme
nous reconnaissons l'existence de liens
intimes avec l'europe le canada et le
japon
pas seulement sur le plan économique
mais aussi sur les plans politique et
militaire ces relations se sont
améliorées
le temps est plus forte qu'il y a
quelques années la communauté européenne
est plus forte avec harry nos relations
avec l'europe et le japon sont plus
fortes
allez conférence au sommet ont contribué
à ce progrès je n'ai jamais considéré
que les intérêts des états unis soit
séparable des intérêts ni du bien-être
de l'alliance occidentale
femmes 1 face au wild en nous référant
rôle et à l'engagement de la france en
afrique en émettant l'hypothèse d'une
autre crise n'a bon c'est vous qu'une
présence occidentale en afrique est
essentielle
un flic à 20 restants soulève tout ou
stay in africa en note ben and in
western country
nos médias pour we are heroes
on est allé jusqu'à destin son côté a
accordé un entretien au journal le monde
avec même en prime un petit croquis pas
très journalistique mais très
intéressant sur les principaux flux à
corriger à la veille du sommet
occidentale de bonnes pour lui la
réduction des importations de pétrole de
même que celle de l'excédent commercial
japonais conditionne le redressement de
l'économie mondiale
et c'est précisément l'un des thèmes que
jimmy carter a également abordé avec une
toute autre optique dans son interview à
jacques séry nous essayons d'accroître
la production chez nous nous essayons de
passer à d'autres formes d'énergie le
charbon l'énergie solaire est incertain
que l'énergie nucléaire
nous essayons aussi d'augmenter les prix
du gaz et du pétrole
déjà nous parlementaires ont accepté
bien des choses mais beaucoup
d'européens ne comprennent pas que nous
ne sommes pas seulement gros
consommateurs de pétrole mais aussi aux
adducteurs il est politiquement
difficile de changer la structure de nos
lois pour réduire les importations de
pétrole et appliqué de strictes mesures
de conservation à long terme il faudra
inverser la tendance change et les
conditions générales du marché et
rétablir l'équilibré commercial point de
l'excédent commercial japonais à bonn ça
passe pour lyon que le japon est aussi
l'allmend grobon stimulent leurs
économies et augmentent leur croissance
de façon être plus à même d'acheter des
produits américains que nous
vendre un prolongement dans une heure
avec notre magazine question de ton en
question de temps pardon à 21h50 donc
magazine consacré à l'amérique
d'aujourd'hui la mecque de jimmy carter
magazine présenté par jean-pierre
elkabbach et puis à 23h05 le dernier
journal berner claude frey merci en vous
quittant tous ceux qui nous ont happé
très très très nombreux pendant ce
journal pour manifester leur solidarité
avec les sinistrés d'espagne et ceux qui
veulent faire don de leur sang
alors je leur signale un numéro de
téléphone celui du centre de transfusion
de l'hôpital saint-antoine à paris de
307 47,28 mais bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'autres hôpitaux en province notamment
voilà je vous remercie donc pour votre
attention pardonner cette longueur
inhabituelle pour ce journal mais je
crois que la qulité été très riche ce
soir je vous retrouve avec plaisir
demain au revoir
à